what the hell is this doesn't anyone
send emails here miles hopefully you
don't mind but we've decided to rebrand
the show to reflect your insistence on
overblowing simple subjects we think
it's a good match I hope you don't mind
those mother over the years customizable
weaponry has become increasingly common
in video games from barrels and sights
too flashy skins or decorative charms
gun loadouts have become a fully
garnished smorgasbord of destruction but
in Rainbow six siege weapon attachments
have become a point of contention for
its fanbase and no other has drawn more
debate than the ACOG the ACOG is it's
everything wrong and good about the game
pretty much it's how you put it people
love it does a long-range for sure it
can be abused it's a sight on a gun you
know what I mean like it's like I don't
think it's like that much of an issue in
the perfect world for me there would be
no echoes in this game at all
so what makes this simple sight such an
issue well let's take a look at it the
advanced combat optical gunsight was
originally designed in 1987 by American
manufacturer Trijicon and it's no
stranger to first-person shooters in
most games the ACOG is a pretty
unremarkable fairly standard tool that's
useful in medium range engagements
but in ubisoft's tactical shooter where
a one bullet headshot from any gun is
enough to kill it's much more than that
the ACOG is the highest magnification
scope in the game and having it equipped
can often be the difference between
losing around and clutching it
or eliminated in siege sightlines angles
and distance are fundamental to
engagements and Ubisoft has attempted to
reflect that with the design of the
operators themselves attackers typically
have access to longer range of salt and
marksman rifles which assists their need
to hold distant angles while working
their way through maps to objectives
defenders on the other hand are equipped
with shorter range weapons like SMGs and
shotguns forcing them to creatively ward
off attackers using the environment and
their utility anyway
this wasn't always the case when siege
first launched the ACOG was available on
a few strange weapons most notably
sledge and smokes SMG 11 aka the sniper
11 the rapid-fire automatic was supposed
to just be a reliable secondary weapon
for the - ops but when it was paired
with the ACOG it became something else
entirely
[Music]
why is this incredibly it took almost a
full year after release before Ubisoft
decided to remove the SMG Elevens ACOG
and following that update debates raged
on about whether it should have happened
and what exactly the games design
philosophy really was Ubisoft is Cregg
it's Abby Robinson pointed out that the
change allowed the devs to expand the
game's design but some people weren't
happy with that answer what did you
expect
although sledge had a good primary that
also had an acog smoke players argued
that he was being neutered because their
preferred weapon was being nerfed but
the SMG 11 was only the beginning and
much larger shockwaves were felt the
following September when Ubisoft
returned for the a cogs of both bandit
and Jaeger
even though by today's standards both
the mp7 and 416 C carbine are still
strong weapons when paired with a
long-range sight they were transformed
into a spawn peakers wet dream despite
Ubisoft's best efforts at trying to make
the overall game more balanced the
community felt betrayed so much so that
thousands of players even signed a
petition pleading for both operators to
get their a cogs back but those cries
fell on deaf ears
fortunately for bandit and Jaeger the
fact that they're both three speed
operators with a wealth of utility
ensured that they remained competitively
viable however that doesn't mean Ubisoft
was above rubbing salt into fans wounds
by memeing on the nerfs anniversary in
2018 and again in 2019 just one pikas
Jagga know now not all ACOG related
nerfs have been met with disdain by
sages fanbase in fact back in March when
Ash's r4c was stripped of its ACOG the
act was celebrated by casual players and
pros alike good riddance
ash is a disgustingly oppressive
operator I don't like to play as ash or
against ash and I think um I think
generally it didn't really change ash
that much ash is still like terrifying I
mean I was one of the people who told
you'll be soft to remove the ash
Eggar like I thought it was too powerful
can't go around the corner while the
ACOG had felt like more of a luxury for
both the Eiger and bandit in some ways
it felt more integral to ash sieges
iconic hyper aggressive Fragger
[Music]
well it's more than just an ACOG because
when we're talking about operators we're
talking about a kit we have their gadget
we have their weapon loadout and then we
have the attachments for that and then
we also have speed so when we're looking
at somebody like ash where she's really
quick she has a really good kit with
weapons and then we have an ACOG on top
of that how do you balance it so one of
the levers we have is okay do we remove
this attachment and she's still strong
enough to stand on the ground the answer
to that question post nerf is an
emphatic yes despite losing the
advantages that previously enjoyed at
all combat ranges with the ACOG her r4c
is still a [__] beast of a weapon the
fact that vital went down to my strength
is really huge too because there's not
gonna be a lot that he can do from the
grave will kill us too and for for the
round vertical while your average ash
main was likely butthurt about the
change high level players were far less
bothered her pick rate might have
dropped but surprisingly her win rate
actually improved even though the most
dangerous a cogwheel during the game
lost it from her best gun some of sieges
best players think that even more
drastic action should be taken in the
perfect world for me there would be no a
copse in this game at all it's too
viable in too many situations it's just
way too powerful in my opinion and the
fact that every attacker has it taken
just all dangles and it's not fun in my
opinion yeah we know if you spot right
now I personally like the idea of having
a more eco ground where let's say in
theory only DMR's headache hogs are only
like stat or players like thermite
Thatcher had eight cars cuz they're
holding angles you know they're doing
that you're staying alive it makes sense
but giving entry Fragger is extremely
powerful weapons with an egg hawk and
the I guess option to play dynamically
you know look at sledge that has an G 11
holo amazing weapon an alien 5 a [__]
amazing weapon you can take every fight
in the game and
the advantage it just seems unfair so
why doesn't Ubisoft just completely get
rid of a cogs if they're such a pain to
balance while the problem with that
approach is that the pic rates of
certain operators with less utility
value would most likely suffer and who
supports that theory better than Doc a3
Armour one speed support character who
because he has an ACOG has established
himself as sieges reigning spawn Pete
God
and while Ubisoft has nerfed dock and
rooks damaged outputs over the last year
their pic rates have remained relatively
high and you have to look at the ACOG as
the cause of that why would you play a
doc for example if you weren't bringing
a cause I mean yeah you can heal
yourself you can Hill teammates there is
some utility there but people who played
are playing for the ACOG essentially
Doc's ACOG has become his most valuable
asset and without it he runs the risk of
becoming irrelevant because his design
doesn't really match Ubisoft's vision
for the game today we learned a lot in
our game you know it's going on five
years now these are operators that we're
talking about have been out for a long
time about what makes a good gadget what
makes a good kit for an operator and how
do they fit in a meta or break a meta
maybe change it in a different way so
when we're talking about rook and we're
talking about Doc these are people that
we've developed a long time ago and we
had no idea how this game was gonna move
thankfully for Doc players and ACOG
enthusiasts it doesn't seem like Ubisoft
has any plans to abolish the optic
entirely instead a shift in direction
for the games map design might be a
viable alternative solution I know we
put a lot of weight into something like
a cogs when a lot of the time we're
dealing more with medium to close range
combat in our game especially the way
with our maps being developed now or
closing rooms in you have to dedicate
yourself to a room and open up longer
line of sights aren't as common it's
becoming more of an interesting play on
what attachments you should bring some
pros already share this sentiment and if
they're mastery of the game is any
indication there is a life after ACOG I
just use it because I'm comfortable with
it but I don't feel like it's like
absolutely necessary I mean it's all
really preference like sometimes you
know there's got to be like a point
where it's like okay I should definitely
run this because it'll just give me the
upper hand
but um there's people out there that
just used strictly 1 X's like a reflex
Hall a red dot and all that and they do
just fine it's all it really all just
comes on the preference or whatever you
feel comfortable with regardless of the
ACOG future there's no question that
it's massively shaped the game scene
just today but in spite of that
influence it's safe to say that certain
people wouldn't miss it if it was gone
Jeremy from a map design perspective the
less I talked the better for me that's
the sugar so what do you guys think of
the acog situation and siege should
Ubisoft remove it from dock like they
did with the other ops let me know what
you think in the comments below but one
thing I'm wondering is who's gonna lose
their ACOG next because you're a liar
and you're a devious clear thanks for
the memories
[Music]
your peanut allergy
excellent give me something give me back
my agog get good boots can't messy shoot
everything